three. The Chiefs like we talked
about their defense has
been strong have allowed eleven
point two points per game
during their five-game
winning streak right now. One
game up on the Chargers. Now,
in the AFC West, we got guys on
the ground, there in Chile,
Kansas City with jackets and
scarves. I hope they're called
as hell.
I hope you guys are freezing,
your butts off. It's nice and
warm here. Let me let me, let me
just say this. Chris. Hey,
thanks for joining the winning
Squad, finally.
Game winning Pick since
September.
I have been tracking it. The
first,
it's a beautiful day for you.
Chris. Welcome to celebrate
both of you. But thank you.
Five wins in a row. Now, for
Kansas City is something blue
directly in my right eye. I'm
going one eye as I fly this
show right now, when you look at
this game tonight, Rod, you
go through this entire game.
Going back to that final drive
right before halftime. They go
20 plays. Do the Broncos and end
up with nothing. What
impact did that have on this?
Let me tell you something
that's devastating, that's
devastating to an offense. You
go 20 plays,
you wear a defense down a
defense is trying to do
everything. They possibly can do
to stop you and you walk
away with no points. That's why
I was so frustrated when they
went for it on. Fourth down,
kick the field goal 20-point,
20 plays and now you score
points. You got to always
anytime you get this opportunity
to score points
in a cold game. This. You have
to take the points.
It was a drive and start all the
way back to the 3-yard
line. They came all the way down
the field. Get absolutely
nothing with it. I thought with
Patrick Mahomes when you watch
him play tonight. What do you
need to see more of from him?
Well, it starts. Wouldn't they
need more discipline? He needs
more discipline.
And that's up to Andy Reid. Andy
Reid's needs to focus on
his footwork. A lot of the fun
fundamentals and tell him,
don't worry about throwing a
ball sidearm or side just focus
on doing things fundamentally
sound just like Chris Simms was
talking about and Chris. I gotta
tell you I could be Walk
in this win. I can't imagine
couldn't even throw the ball to
that 10 yard marker right there.
What did you see from Patrick
Mahomes trying to throw it
through this stuff tonight.
Well, I think you know Rodney
hit on a lot of the right
points. And again just think
I want to see more consistency
from Patrick Mahomes in
the passing offense, you know,
still for a guy as talented as
he is,
you know, yes, we've become
accustomed to hitting
the sidearm throw and making it
happen, but he's not
the machine. He was in your
past. Hey, here's here's one.
That's
great. I mean, come on. Nobody.
Does that better than Patrick?
Mahoney is running lat.
Going back, right? But it's
these plays again. Hey, that's
pretty good. But I'd like to see
Tyree kill. Catch the ball
running. Everybody got an extra
five, ten yards. It's off just
a little bit and then plays like
this, where the receiver
can't even get a
hand on the football or you got
Travis Kelce opened on a why
out tight end out route. Throws
it at his feet. That's what I'm
not accustomed to seeing Rodney,
hit it right. Feet are
all over the place at times.
Let's his arm get too loose.
Doesn't get his body in the
right positions to be the
Throwing the football. Like,
we've seen him, be our like, a
Brady, or an Aaron Rodgers,
how they can be.
And Chris is going to go down as
a Kansas City blowout,
right? But something still looks
a little bit weird about
this. Kansas City offense. What
do you think? It is? Watching
them play
and and Chris maybe you agree
with me, but I think what
they're missing is that third
guy in the passing game. Yeah,
you know you have heel, you have
Kelsey and those guys can
make plays but they're really
missing that third guy,
Demarcus Robinson. He tried
to give him an opportunity. He
hasn't really taken advantage
of it. Talk about buying
Pringle. He had two drops. He's
not taking advantage of it.
Clyde Edward tool are he's back
there? Trying to get him
involved, but they need that.
Weapon
in the passing game. Your
thoughts, Chris
gree, I mean, especially when
you're, when you're a team
built through the offense,
right? Sorry to cut you off
there Jack, but I think that's a
real thing. There's no doubt
about it, you know, team built
through the offense. They want
to score points put pressure
on you that way.
But Rodney, you know, the great
offense is you defend and your
career, like the Indianapolis
Colts. They had more than two
guys, right? It was Reggie,
Wayne Marvin Harrison, and
Edgerrin, James and Dallas
Clark. You go back to like
the greatest show on Turf the
Rams,
you know. Oh, Isaac, Bruce
Torry, Holt and Marshall fog.
I think it's a very real point.
You bring up. It's easy to take
two people out of a game plan.
It's that third one that can
put an offense over the top and
Rodney. I think you're
kind of on to something there
that and I'd like to see where's
the speed sweeps. The
reverses wide receiver screen
game. That is another thing.
I would like to see from Kansas
City, bring some defenses up.
So then you can give me the
ball,
right? You can get, you can now
be creative and throw the ball
down the field, what we're
accustomed to seeing from them.